First thing I would do
is not only leave the Netherlands,
leave the European Union,
but also stop the immigration from Islamic countries.
Which doesn't mean that the Muslims are there
and hollanded they should leave.
Everybody was already in my country today.
And everybody who adheres and confirms its behaviour
to our Constitution,
our law, our rule of law and our civil society.
And is, is, um,
welcome to stay and equal as anybody else.
But since my party believes,
and millions of people who support us today,
that Islam and freedom,
Islam and democracy
are incompatible.
Indeed, we're not saying that all Muslims are bad people.
We would want to stop the immigration
and the import of more people from Islamic countries.
We will do that the same day.